à casablanca au maroc rassemblement hier
en soutien aux journalistes
omar radi mobilisation devant le
tribunal où le militant des droits de
l'homme était entendu par un juge
d'instruction en détention préventive
depuis fin juillet omar à 10 34 ans est
incarcéré pour financement étranger
atteinte à la sécurité intérieure de
l'état et viole les accusations
fabriquées de toutes pièces selon ses
proches certains médias et plusieurs ong
pour qui omar radi a été arrêté en
raison de ses opinions
[Musique]
nous espérons mettre fin à cette farce
pourquoi détenir quelqu'un qui offre
toutes les garanties pour se présenter à
son procès regardez le niveau de
solidarité locale et internationale
envers lui toutes les charges retenues
contre lui sont fabriqués personne ne
les crois nous faisons confiance à notre
justice mais omar devraient être libérés
même temporairement
il devrait également bénéficier d'un
procès équitable
j'espère que ce qui se passe n'est
qu'une erreur qui sera corrigée l'état
devrait suivre une approche différente
avec les journalistes parce que la
manière dont il traite la presse
n'apportera rien de bon
notre message premier est que le
journalisme n'est pas un crime la seule
chose qu omar a fait c'est d'exercer son
métier de journaliste jusqu'au bout dans
les limites de la loi marocaine
il a fait son travail de journaliste
d'investigation pour informer les
marocains il a peut-être traiter des
questions très délicate mais elle était
en faveur de la société marocaine